(laughs)
- I follow you on Twitter,
- I follow you on Twitter.
- And I think you follow
me on twitter as well,
but you're not on the 'gram!
- I'm not.
- For someone named Lauren Graham.
- I know.
- Yeah, it's kind of funny.
- This is what happened is,
so the woman who played
my mom on Gilmore Girls,
Kelly Bishop, who's incredible,
who is in the original
cast of A Chorus Line--
- And also Dirty Dancing, fine.
- And also Dirty Dancing,
and I went to look her
up to find a video of her
from A Chorus Line, and
literally when I looked up,
I was 72 years old.
I had been like, I had
spent so long on the
TV, or on the thing, like,
getting so distracted,
- Oh, you went into the hole.
- Because I went through the Chorus Line,
and then I was watching old
clips of old other musicals,
and it's just not--
I'm a person who opens
the refrigerator door
and walks away and
forgets, like it's just,
I'm easily distracted,
I guess is the point.
I am worried if I was on Instagram I would
never do anything else.
- You know what?
My key is, I only use it
because I was against all of it
in the beginning, 'cause I was like,
"This is a lot, and why do people care
how I like my coffee?
And why are there so many
food posts? Like, I don't
care what you're eating
and it's probably you're
skinny and you're eating
something I wanna eat and I can't,
so I don't wanna see it."
So it's just like, I just started doing it
just for work.
I thought it was--
it was kinda cool 'cause fans get to like,
"I'm a nerd over you."
So, it's kinda cool 'cause
fans get to see stuff
or whatever, and they get a little inside.
But, I get it. It's a lot.
- It is really cool.
- All the things is a lot.
- But it's fun.
I have met some wonderful
people who I admire,
you know, and that's the connectivity of
all that stuff is really nice.
- Yeah, amen.